[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
well if you've been paying attention to
the news for the last 24 hours you've
probably already heard the blockbuster
revelation that Justin Bieber is now one
of the three artists to score
back-to-back number-one songs in the
United States twice I'm obviously
kidding that's not really news but we do
have really really big breaking news
here's the real breaking news Pat got
scared Pat thought I had changed the
first story on the show all of a sudden
now we've crossed some kind of red line
with Donald Trump's presidency it has
been revealed that Donald Trump in the
Oval Office the day after firing FBI
director James Comey Donald Trump
revealed highly classified intelligence
information to none other than Sergey
Lavrov the Russian Foreign Minister and
Sergey Kiss lyac the Russian ambassador
to the u.s. who is at the center of the
Trump Russia investigation and by the
way is also a suspected Russian spy
recruiter as first reported by The
Washington Post yesterday the
intelligence was related to an Isis plot
according to officials we know that the
information came from a Middle Eastern
Ally that closely guards its own secrets
the information was considered so
sensitive that American officials didn't
share it widely even within our own
government nevermind
pass it on to other allies and Trump
spills it to Russia
now let's circumvent or step get around
one of the main questions first which is
is this strictly speaking illegal no
because the President does have the
power to declassify anything they want
to declassify so by sharing it Trump has
effectively Declassified it however this
is a major national security risk it is
a major diplomatic blunder it's a total
breach of espionage and intelligence
etiquette and protocol which could
drastically jeopardize our relationships
with other countries with regard to
intelligence sharing I mean that why
would any Ally share information with us
now Trump might just spill it to Russian
spy recruiters in the Oval Office
think that is one of the most telling
things because if we're not able to give
this to our allies apparently we can
give it to our adversaries yes but I
don't think it was that strategic it
seems as if Trump was trying to brag in
front of them and that's certainly what
the Washington Post article reflects and
I'm going to get to that because the
bragging aspect of this is big it's
actually even worse than I've even told
you so far because the ally that we
received this information from according
to an American official the ally had
already warned us that they would cut
off access to sensitive information like
this if we were to share it too widely
and I think Trump mentioning it to
Russian officials in the Oval Office
would constitute sharing it too widely
despite it not being illegal this is
also a mishandling
by Donald Trump a careless act of by
Donald Trump with regard to secret
information so I think we should go to
none other than Donald Trump himself in
terms of how we should deal with people
who were careless with sensitive
information I will call your attention
to Donald Trump's tweet from July 6th of
2016 where Donald Trump said crooked
Hillary Clinton and her team were
extremely careless in their handling a
very sensitive highly classified
information not fit now the controversy
actually grew when general HR McMaster
Trump's national security adviser
initially denied the reports which are
being widely corroborated by others
McMaster said quote I was in the room it
didn't happen at no time at no time were
intelligence sources or methods
discussed and the president did not
disclose any military operations that
were not already publicly known given
how many bogus denials we've heard from
Trump cronies time and again this isn't
particularly convincing but Donald
Trump's own statements contradict
mcmaster donald trump sent two tweets
this morning where he said as president
i wanted to share with russia at an
openly scheduled White House meeting
which I have the absolute right to do
facts pertaining to terrorism and
airline flight safety humanitarian
reasons plus I want Russia to greatly
step up their fight against Isis and
terrorism
so Trump is not denying that he did this
he's basic
saying hey I had my reasons for doing it
it seems like very unorganized damage
control because all these surrogates are
saying different things and even
Republicans think this is insane
bob Corker who's a Tennessee senator or
a Balcon who endorsed Trump early sure
said that he thinks that the White House
is in a downward spiral
you have Susan Collins a Maine senator
who said can we just have one crisis
free day so it looks like the wheels are
falling off spiral is not particularly
downward spiral but spiral alone is not
really a word you want being used to
describe your administration by people
within your own party and again there
have been conflicting reports but
according to officials Trump discuss the
contents of the intelligence not the
sources and methods used to collect it
official said that Trump shared granular
details of the intelligence with
Russians including the city in Syria
where the ally picked up the information
about the ISIS plot so again big picture
one of the people Trump shared this
information with is a Russian spy
recruiter suspected Russian spy
recruiter Sergey kis lyac
here's another blockbuster element of
The Washington Post report on this The
Washington Post story says quote one of
assistant to the president for Homeland
Security and counterterrorism Thomas P
Bossard subordinates also called and you
have to pay real close attention to this
called for the problematic portion of
Trump's discussion to be stricken from
internal memos and for the full
transcript to be limited to a small
circuit small circle of recipients
stricken from the internal memos and for
the full transcript to be limited this
suggests it basically directly says that
there's a full transcript of the meeting
the meeting was likely recorded this
could escalate very quickly if a formal
investigation begins and again this
could not get more Nick Sounion there
could be oval office recordings of the
president giving classified information
to a suspected Russian spy recruiter and
the context from those in the room and
this gets to the bragging part that Pat
mentioned Trump appear
to do this to sort of boast about the
great intelligence that he gets how
insecure do you have to be to become
president of the United States and still
brag about job perks like intelligence
briefings to foreign diplomats and
remember that this meeting happened one
day after Donald Trump fired FBI
director James Comey Lee of course the
guy investigating him so it just gives
the appearance at least that he's
sucking up to the Ambassador and the
Foreign Minister there and when you look
at the Russian allegations does that
seem more or less likely after we know
this now absolutely and and the counter
is we'll listen if Trump really were in
bed with the Russians he wouldn't be
doing any of this because it's so
obviously paints this picture of
collusion we don't know what Trump would
be doing in any circumstances because
you've got against what we would imagine
someone would do at just about every
step but you know what Pat so what Trump
leaked classified info to a suspected
Russian spy recruiter in the Oval Office
who cares just get over that Hillary
loss right I mean the emails the Clinton
Foundation Obama wore a tan suit once
all these liberals need to stop talking
about this it seems as if Donald Trump
might be contradicting himself on this
one yes a rarity we've not seen that
happen ever before in the past after
Donald Trump has made indefensible false
claims about you know Obama wasn't born
in the US or Obama wiretapped me Trump
would be in interviews and the
interviewer would try to ask him for
evidence of the claims and try to see
whether Trump still believes these
claims and very often Trump would just
try to steer the conversation in another
direction saying oh that's an old
subject or you'll found out find out
from someone else or no one cares about
that or something like that like for
example when John Dickerson was
interviewing Donald Trump in the Oval
Office not long ago and asked about the
Obama wiretapped knee claims and Trump
abruptly ended the interview and kicked
Dickerson out of his office those
situations always seem like they sort of
should be really embarrassing for Donald
Trump if it's even possible for Trump to
be embarrassed
last week just a few days after Trump
fired FBI director James Comey
Trump had yet another one of these weird
defensive outbursts on Twitter we
covered this yesterday where Donald
Trump tweeted James Comey better hope
that there are no quote tapes of our
conversations before he starts leaking
to the press
Trump has tweeted endless asinine things
over the years including while he's been
in office as the president he's had to
put his foot in his mouth many times
sometimes it's lies sometimes it's an
immature rant but this is actually one
of the most serious and bold claims that
Trump is made on Twitter it was it was
basically a threat to James Comey right
this Trump think he can just tweet
whatever he wants as long as he puts
certain words in quotes Obama quote
wiretapped me James Comey better not
have any hope there are no tapes quote
tapes is this some kind of tip maybe
Trump's got from a lawyer you put these
words in quotes it's like he's trying to
distance himself from the allegation but
the thing is if there are tapes Trump
would be the one to know about them
right absolutely why he's bringing them
up in the first place so all of a sudden
Trump gets asked about the tapes in an
interview with Fox News's Jeanine Pirro
suddenly he doesn't want to talk about
the tapes anymore right after he posted
the tweet the White House refused to
confirm or deny whether the tapes exist
Spicer the press secretary Sean Spicer
completely stonewalled during a press
briefing and when Trump sat down for an
interview with Fox News anchor host
whatever Jeanine Pirro Trump flat out
refuses to discuss the existence of the
tapes take a look at this what about the
idea that in a tweet you said that there
might be tape recordings that I can't
talk about I won't talk about that all I
want is for coming to be honest and I
hope he will be and I'm sure he will be
I hope okay and so let this new director
of the FBI yeah he'll talk about the new
director so of course Fox News doesn't
press him on it at all moving right
along to the next question
uh in spite of the fact that what we you
you tweeted would be a blockbuster if it
were true so just like with many of
other Trump's of trumps of outrageous
assertions he again makes it never
presenting evidence to begin with
then avoids being held accountable for
the statement when he's asked about it
the cat is out of the bag here if you
don't want to talk about that why did
you choose to tweet it to the entire
world it's just such a dumb thing to say
because if there are tapes then they can
be suspended subpoenaed by the Democrats
who are conducting an investigation
against them and if there aren't tapes
then that removes any leverage you would
claim to have over James Comey so
there's only a third option there which
is to not confirm or deny the existence
of them and to try to sort of glean some
benefit from the possibility that maybe
they exist but as you're pointing out
what would that benefit be if you don't
actually have the goods it's so
ridiculous that even prominent
Republicans are calling Trump out on
this Lindsey Graham who's a Republican
senator from South Carolina said over
the weekend quote you can't be cute
about tapes if there are any tapes of
this conversation they need to be turned
over and I doubt if there are if the
tapes exist they would be of much
interest to the many committees and
agencies investigating the Trump Russia
connections any recordings related to
the firing of James Comey could be
evidence that indicates whether Donald
Trump criminally obstructed justice in
the investigation and if the tapes are
real if any of Trump's statements or
actions regarding the firing of James
Comey constitute anything like
obstruction of justice this may be the
closest that we've ever gotten to a
material prospect of an impeachment of
Donald Trump but these are all really
really big IFS congressional Democrats
and Republicans are saying that the
tapes if they exist should and will be
subpoenaed I saw an interview today with
one of the lawyers that was involved in
the Watergate scandal he made it pretty
clear that it's not going to be an easy
task to subpoena those tapes even if
they do exist so this is something we're
going to be watching very very closely
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman send me your
thoughts about this the show is on
twitter at david packard show the david
pakman show at david pakman
[Applause]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the day
is Joshua Hart Joshua thank you thank
you for signing up at david pakman.com
slash membership we are not only an
independently funded program we depend
on the funding of members like Joshua we
also are trying to make up a significant
amount of lost revenue from what is now
called YouTube ad pocalypse I spoke
about that yesterday so please continue
to sign up like Joshua did at david
pakman.com slash membership we have a
coupon code
I voted 17 which you can use to get a
big discount off of membership you can
also pledge as little as $1 a month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show even
a dollar a month helps and of course
remember that you can pick up david
pakman show coffee bumper stickers and
apparel at david pakman.com slash gear
lastly check out love in the time of
coffee calm this is a documentary
upcoming documentary from long time show
supporter Greg Stevens and the
documentary is going to show it's going
to basically explore globalization
agriculture trade employment so many
different areas of life through the lens
of coffee they've got a fundraiser that
they're working on you can check out
more at love in the time of coffee calm
alright my popular Instagram pictures
from this week of course i'm on
instagram at david pakman let's go first
to the first of the most popular
pictures from my instagram account this
week i tweeted over the weekend myself
sitting cross-legged no less with my
Kosmos by carl sagan book this is a book
I recently finished I never read the
book previously I know this is a book
that lots of people read a long time ago
it is from the early 80s fantastic book
I am probably going to recommend this on
an upcoming recommendation segment have
you ever read to Kosmos path I have not
may have a new TV series right with Neil
deGrasse Tyson right I have to check
that out yeah oh the new TV series is
great the original
is extraordinary obviously like with
everything that I post to Instagram
immediately I was criticized because I
waited too long to read the book yes the
book was written before I was born and I
only just now read it but I read the
book isn't that a good thing shouldn't
we be focusing on that no I think we
should focus on the fact that you read
sitting on the floor crisscross
applesauce NOLA yeah I well let's move
on to picture number two please before
this becomes an even bigger scandal okay
the other very popular picture from my
Instagram account over the last week
David Pakman is a drawing of me by
Instagram user I am Lord this is very
cool this is based on a travel picture I
posted a few weeks ago during our show
vacation and it was me reading at a cafe
in Brussels Belgium and that has been
turned Patt into this drawing of me and
I think it's pretty cool I like this
yeah very calm expression there which I
think drives with the style of art and I
would love to see a YouTube livestream
thumbnail of yours done in this style as
a drawing right yeah that is interesting
so anyway if any of this sounds
interesting you can follow me on
instagram at david pakman and thanks to
IM lor for putting that picture that
drawing together very very cool all
right
tons of people emailing me saying David
you aren't covering the blockbuster DNC
lawsuit cover it this is huge
well I'm going to cover it and I want to
explain to you why it isn't getting much
coverage there is a sort of corporate
media blackout on this lawsuit but
there's a reason why and I'm going to
explain it to you and the reason why is
that the lawsuit is going nowhere and I
know people are going to hear me say
this no say David how dare you how dare
you say it's going nowhere there is a
major story that you may have seen
floating around online and the major
story is a corporate media blackout on a
DNC lawsuit well what are the merits of
the lawsuit what are the facts of the
case a lawsuit has been filed against
the Democratic National Committee for
their alleged favoring of Hillary
Clinton over Bernie Sanders during the
2016
primary this has been filed as a class
action in US district court by residents
of 45 states against both the DNC and
specifically against Debbie
wasserman-schultz the then DNC chair for
quote intentional willful wanton and
malicious conduct in violating article 5
section 4 of the Democratic National
Committee's Charter there are three
classes of plaintiffs here donors to the
DNC donors to Bernie Sanders's campaign
and all registered Democrats on April
25th the court held a hearing on a
motion to dismiss the DNC's lawyers
argued we have every right to pick
candidates in the back rooms and favor
candidates if that's what we want to do
there has been very little coverage of
it the lawyers for the DNC are saying
that Sanders supporters were aware that
the primaries were effectively rigged
and that neutrality is a political
promise that cannot be enforced by a
court basically the argument from DNC
lawyers is this is our internal Charter
we're not legally bound to it thus the
lawsuit is bogus this is an affirmative
defense right rather than denying that
they rigged the primaries or were you
know pushing the scale for one candidate
over another they're saying there's
nothing stopping the DNC from helping
one candidate win over another why isn't
this going to get much coverage because
the DNC is basically right I am the
first person to tell you yeah the DNC
did favor Hillary Clinton they favored
her they did they made decisions with
regard to the debate scheduling a number
of debates timing et cetera that was
meant to help Hillary Clinton in many
ways they were strategizing together
with the Hillary Clinton campaign
against Bernie Sanders but whatever
Democrats internal Charter says that
they are supposed to be a neutral
arbiter of the primary unless individual
donors can prove that some kind of real
fraud was committed which even if we
colloquially think that that could be
demonstrated is very hard to do legally
this is going nowhere so I'm not
defending corporate media for not cover
this but I'm explaining to you why this
is going nowhere people are going to be
mad at me for saying this it's not going
anywhere yeah well I mean it's easy to
forget sometimes that the Democratic
Party is a private institution so you're
right they don't have to adhere to their
own charter but I think the people
bringing this class-action lawsuit are
looking for some sort of symbolic
victory and I think that's what they're
able to get because if the DNC's lawyers
have to make concessions of the fact
that yeah we did rig this and Bernie
Sanders supporters knew about it I think
that's good enough I think that's sort
of a win in and of itself you think I
don't know that there are too many of
the people that are emailing me saying
David you've got to cover this and
corporate media won't cover it I don't
know that they're going to be happy with
a symbolic victory because they're still
emailing me even though they already got
the symbolic victory right I could see
them wanting to have some sort of
repercussions when it comes to debbie
Wasserman Schultz okay but what do you
want the Democratic Party to be fined
and thus your ability to run effective
candidates in 2018 and 2022 be hindered
that's it that's a fair question and I
don't know the answer to that and I I
want to be clear I agree with the
allegations made by the lawsuit I just
don't believe that the lawsuit itself is
going to do anything
and obviously the Democratic Party isn't
that Democratic super-delegates right I
mean the ability for individuals to
overrule large swathes of Democratic
voters we knew that it wasn't really
democratic to begin with and that's not
a surprise at all but that if you
disagree about where the lawsuit will go
let me know right and then I'll follow
up well luckily when debbie Wasserman
Schultz was ousted they replaced her
with someone who was completely
impartial being Donna Brazile yes Donna
Brazile came in and then everything was
fine there's a talked about the new
front on LGBT rights now that gay
marriage is legal the legality of firing
people based on their sexual orientation
so-called religious freedom bills that's
the sort of new front against LGBT
rights to take one example currently in
Missouri like in many states it's
illegal to fire someone merely for being
gay last week the Missouri State House
of Representatives was debating a bill
that would protect LGBT people from
being fired for their sexual orientation
the
ended up going backwards okay the
amendment protecting gay people was
removed and they ended up passing a bill
that would make it more difficult for
all people to sue for discriminatory
termination from their jobs and while
they were debating there's this
Republican state representative in
Missouri I should say Missouri that's I
guess that's how it's said right I think
either one is accepted okay very good
Missouri Republican Missouri state
representative Rick brattin
was against keeping the language in the
bill that would have protected gay
people he basically said on the House
floor that gay people they're not really
people okay here's what he said quote
when you look at the tenets of religion
of the Bible of the Koran of other
religions there is a distinction between
homosexuality and just being a human
being this is not just a reprehensible
thing to say on a moral level it's
legally fallacious based on a document
that people like Bratton claimed to pray
at the altar of we know it is the
Constitution number one you've got this
thing called the Equal Protection Clause
of the 14th amendment which guarantees
equal protection of all people under the
law unless you can legally demonstrate
that a gay person is not homo sapiens
the Constitution does not distinguish
between LGBT people and other people and
the Supreme Court has actually affirmed
that and number two he's citing holy
books as justification for
discrimination against LGBT people by
the government that defines that defies
the Establishment Clause of the First
Amendment separation of church and state
but what's most intolerable about Braton
statements is the contempt he's showing
for people in his state right there are
LGBT Missourians who are presumably
finding out about what Bratton said and
this is someone who's supposed to be
there to represent them he's been asked
for comment he hasn't responded this is
not just ignorance at the level of a
single person to say something so stupid
this is the general attitude and
rationale of many conservatives now that
want to deny LGBT people their rights
now that gay marriage has the
legalised and of course he's bringing
religion into this conversation which is
not commonplace I mean you can't have
that when we have the First Amendment
guarantee if separation of church and
state correct but since he's bringing up
political or to be bringing up the Bible
it's important to point out that the
Bible also says he who is without sin
cast the first stone
meaning possibly he's gay himself and is
just projecting it onto other people
obviously not all homophobes are gay but
the number of religious conservatives
who have devoted their lives to making
the lives of LGBT people miserable who
have later sort of come out as gay or
lesbian or bisexual or transgender it's
odd it's very very odd and it does point
to this idea that sometimes because you
are not able to live in the world the
way you truly authentically feel you
don't want anybody who B to be able to
live in the world in that way and that's
actually sad I mean I know that we've
talked about this many times Pat about
the homophobes who are gay it's actually
a really sad thing because clearly their
lives are difficult as a result of not
being able to live in the world as who
they are and they're also making the
lives of other people more difficult
right exactly you can't feel too badly
about that even though they're obviously
conflicted in their in their inside
their own head because they're trying to
make life worse for everyone else this
also proves that anyone who says hey
religion and politics is good they're
wrong right I mean Pat's pointing that
out these types of conservative
politicians have religious beliefs that
they believe to be sort of literal
worldly beliefs and when they apply them
to the way that government govern those
beliefs have consequences and in this
case people are being denied which
should be basic rights
how many months by the way before this
guy gets caught performing sex acts on a
man in a public bathroom would anyone be
surprised if this guy ends up adopting a
wide stance in an airport men's room
like former Republican Senator Larry
Craig but that aside Bratton is a guy
who's advocated teaching creationism in
public schools in science class he's
pushed for a law that would require the
permission of a father for a young woman
to get an abortion
he was an ally of fellow Republican
Missouri State Representative
Achan who's famous for saying if it's a
legitimate rape the female body has a
way to try to shut the whole thing down
this is a damaging individual to the
lives of so many men women LGBT
individuals and this is the exact it's
just a microcosm of who we should not
have determining the direction of
government at the state or federal level
a couple of discussions about this on
our reddit discussion forums which I
invite you to join at david patten.com
explore wordpress credit the david
pakman show at david pakman.com welcome
back to the David Pakman show I'm joined
today by Dan Hyman who's a reporter for
public news service Dan you were at the
center of a controversy that sort of
went viral a few days ago you were
actually arrested for asking a question
apparently at a volume and with a tone
that not everybody liked to health
secretary Tom Price it's been picked up
by a number of news outlets and you've
been talking about what's going on so
first and foremost let's talk about what
what's your typical beat as a reporter
well I'm based in Charleston West
Virginia and I've I've been with the
public news service since 2009 and I've
always covered West Virginia we covered
state-by-state in that time I've also
covered other states but but I've always
covered West Virginia so talk to us
about the circumstances under which Tom
Price was going to be what you were
going to be covering Tom Price and sort
of what the event was and how the
situation surfaced well I was working on
a story about the impact of the crop
care the Republican health care proposal
on victims of domestic violence I was
already working on that story and I had
been you know been trying to gather some
information about this and saw that
secretary price was going to be in town
for something unrelated and was going to
be at the Capitol so I decided to go
down and see if I could get him to
answer a question about this
specifically whether or not
domestic violence would be considered a
pre-existing condition because before
the Affordable Care Act before Obamacare
there were instances where battered
women and men there probably a few who
lose lost their health insurance because
they the domestic violence or the damage
caused by domestic violence was a
pre-existing condition so I went down to
try and get him to answer this question
so you show up down there had he given
someone had had he already spoken at the
time when you approached to try to ask a
question or what were the circumstances
no he was entering the building and was
on his way to a meeting that was close
to the public later on he did I'm told
answer four questions although I didn't
know about that um and but it but he was
just entering the building it's a public
space and reporters do this all the time
as he was walking down the hall I
reached out my phone to him had my phone
recording and I asked him you know this
question and he didn't say anything in
that kind of situation you're never sure
whether the the person you're trying to
talk to is doesn't want to say anything
or they're ignoring you or whether maybe
they just didn't hear you or you didn't
hear their response so I asked him a
couple more times and you know nobody
pulled me back nobody told me you know
stay away from secretary price nobody
you know grabbed my arm
no one even really identified themselves
as law enforcement until I was arrested
and I was I was pulled off taken to a
room that the capital in handcuffs and
they sent me a way to end up in an
orange jumpsuit ultimately you were
arrested for willful disruption of state
government processes what what exactly
does that mean as far as you've
investigated and and at what point did
it become clear that it was sort of the
the volume and way in which you asked
this question that caused this entire
thing I really have no idea what that
law means I mean my lawyer says that it
may be unconstitutionally vague and I I
think he may be right about that it may
have been in court basically what this
is is the law that they use to if
somebody for example is in the gallery
of the legislature during the
legislative session or interrupts a
meeting or something and you know shouts
out and you know tries to disrupt the
meeting that they can be you know
arrested using this on it's a
problematic statute and the other thing
then this is something else my lawyers
pointed out that's kind of problematic
is what process what governmental
process was i interrupting hmm I mean
the man was walking down the hallway I
wasn't it was like he was you know
meeting with the governor and some kind
of you know during a thunderstorm or you
know
it gives it a grandiosity that doesn't
really make sense and and my my
suspicion is is that the police the
Capitol Police who arrested me I don't
think there was any kind of a an order
come down from on high you know keep the
keep the press away from this guy um
there were some protesters there and the
the Trump administration and secretary
price has been very tightly controlling
their public access regarding this this
health care legislation they don't
really like talking about it
and Dan let me get a few with
just before we move off of the the
specifics of the arrogant number one or
were you sort of noticeably identifiable
as a reporter like did you have a press
pass for example or something
identifying public news service right I
had a press pass on my chest on the
lanyard and I had a shirt on that said
public news service now I because it had
been raining I also had a jacket on so I
don't think my shirt was visible but
when the police arrested me I told him I
was a reporter and I told them that I
was just doing my job
and they arrested me anyway did you at
any point make any physical contact with
the secretary no now I was never close
enough to make physical contact with the
secretary and in fact later on he's done
some interviews he told conservative
talk show hosts that the the talk-show
host asked him you know was I quote
menacing and price said no not really no
he wasn't it I barely noticed him you
know and at this depth that kind of fits
because as I said reporters do this all
the time I mean if you google Tom Price
you know talking to reporters in
hallways you could pull up you know
images of him answering questions
walking down the hallway and in
Washington DC and Dan there's one quote
I saw that says from from some authority
I'm not sure exactly who it is that's
quoted that you were because you were
aggressively breaching personal space
that you were actually removed quote a
couple of times from the area is that
true where you had you already been
removed before this incident no um I
think that well that's actually in the
criminal report and I think that that
may be a case of the Capitol policeman
trying to make this sound as good as
possible
I was not removed from the hallway this
all took place in the in the hallway in
one continuous more-or-less motion and I
was not removed from that
way we were all still in the same room
yeah no one pulled me back no one
grabbed me by my arm
no one pulled me away no one said don't
do that anymore
on the I think the only thing that we
can assume they mean there is because I
was trying to reach past who I assumed
at the time was secretary prices staff
although in retrospect they may have
been some of them may have been Secret
Service agents yeah they were not
identified as such being well Secret
Service agents um but I was trying to
reach past them with my phone and they
were you know pushing against me and and
I was you know I did that a few times in
that I tried to sort of jockey around
the entourage or to try and get a better
angle on secretary price but no I was
never removed last thing dan what are
the repercussions for you legally now
that you've been charged with willful
disruption of state government processes
well this is a misdemeanor but it's a
it's a pretty stout one I face
I think the magistrate said a year my
lawyer said that really means six months
but there's a potential of six months in
jail and I think a $500 fine it was
$5,000 bail Wow my yeah my network put
up I think they put up 10% of that arm
but it's it's a you know it's not to be
underestimated I don't I'm not I think
most juries are going to stand with a
free press I mean in this country we
really believe in reporters being able
to do their jobs and have your lawyers
said you know here's how you should be
thinking about the possibility of jail
time if they sort of handicapped it for
you for lack of a better term not really
um I mean II have said that we want to
fight this some of that may be because
we want to make a point but also I think
he feels like we've got a pretty good
case yeah um
hasn't said you know if you go there
Jaeho you know here's what you should do
it would be it's a little bit concerning
the thought of going to jail for six
months but on say I feel yeah but I do
feel good that we have a strong case
we've been speaking with dan Hyman the
reporter from public news service who
was arrested for asking questions to
Health and Human Services Secretary Tom
Price dan we're going to be following
what goes on and I really appreciate you
telling me about how it went down today
yeah stay in touch
hopefully we'll have some news when
waiting when it was hopefully when they
drop the curtain the david pakman show
at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
during a normal day from the Donald
Donald administration we can be so
overwhelmed with the craziness and the
news that it's hard to keep up with
everything that happens and this past
week has been particularly wild right I
mean Trump fire James Comey the
revealing secrets to Russians in the
Oval Office thing it's been a crazy week
and that's why many people haven't
noticed that the director of the Census
Bureau John Thompson has suddenly
announced his resignation which will
take effect at the end of June this may
be as important as the departure of
James Comey I've been talking about the
census since November 9th probably even
before that the 2020 census and this is
huge the Census happens every 10 years
the Constitution outlines that the
census will take place the census
determines how federal money gets
distributed it determines how
congressional district lines are drawn
and it relates to gerrymandering it's
what makes people politically visible we
did recently did a long-form video about
gerrymandering and the impact that the
2020 census will have on redistricting
in the decade that follows this is going
to impact House elections for years to
come
and it's at the core of what our
national politics will look like
Thompson
served in the position of Director of
the census since 2013 his term wasn't
supposed to end until next year and the
fact that there won't be a director is a
major issue the time leading up to the
2020 census is critical people may not
realize this but the census is not
something that happens like in the year
before you actually do the census as
soon as one census is done the planning
starts for the next census and it
basically last 10 years we know how slow
Donald Trump is when it comes to filling
important leadership positions and even
when he fills those positions there's a
good chance that it's going to be an
ideologue and someone we should actually
not want running the census budget
problems can linger for agencies that
don't have a director because they don't
have someone there advocating for money
if the census is underfunded that's a
really bad thing I'm very concerned
about this and it's not making almost
any headlines
I've been talking about the census for
months and months if not years it's so
important and now there's no one in
charge of the boat well John Thompson
who's the outgoing census director has a
background as a statistician which is
something that you would expect out of
someone in that role to given Donald
Trump's cabinet picks you know people
who are just ideologically opposed with
the positions that they have to fulfill
sure we can only expect some someone
like chris Christie or like a bright
bart reporter or a Wall Street guy to
take over you're right I mean the guy
who trump appointed to be effectively
the head scientist of the USDA is a
Christian conservative radio talk show
host with no background in science
the guy who trump appointed to be
Secretary of Energy Rick Perry is
someone who didn't want the Department
of Energy to exist but actually forgot
that that was one of the departments he
wanted to abolish the guy who drained
the swamp by hiring his family members
to work in the White House and
appointing billionaires and Wall Street
finance executives and tycoons to
important positions in Washington is the
guy who's going to put someone in there
who's qualified to direct the census if
Trump puts someone qualified in to run
the census it will be a mere coincidence
I mean it won't be the result of proper
planning and selection and history has
also shown us that Trump may be likely
to nominate someone who is just hugely
partisan and that would be just as bad
as someone who's unqualified to run the
Census so I am so concerned about this
it can impact politics obviously it
impacts politics for 10 years but it can
also impact politics much longer if you
consider that then you will are more
likely to have Republicans deciding who
will head up the next census this is
really not a good thing yeah I think if
there's any silver lining here though is
that the census has a lot to do with
data where people live demographic
breakdown it's not too political where
it gets political is when you take that
information give it over to the state
legislatures and then they are in charge
of drawing the district lines that's
where gerrymandering comes in that's
where the the issue really takes hold no
doubt about it and we've been covering
that and we're going to continue
covering it late last week Donald Trump
issued an executive order creating the
Presidential Commission on election
integrity this is
a this is an office that is going to try
to fight against voter fraud which of
course doesn't exist looking to solve a
problem that does not exist for people
in 2016 were caught committing voter
fraud three of those people were
Republicans who presumably voted for
Trump there were 31 cases of voter
impersonation from 2000 to 2014 the
reality about so-called voter fraud
investigations and legislation is that
it's a way to suppress Democratic and
minority votes remember Donald Trump has
a lot of ego riding on this he tweeted
as I'm sure you remember in addition to
winning the electoral college in a
landslide I won the popular vote if you
deduct the millions of people who voted
illegally now Trump's own lawyers have
said there's actually no evidence of
significant voter fraud from the 2016
presidential election not only is that
based on Trump's debunked claims that
quote millions voted illegally in the
election the two people that Trump has
put in charge of this commission have
horrible track records of suppressing
voter turnout who's running this
abortion of a commission while Mike
Pence is going to be the chair in
October of 2016
it's what 2016 under pence the indiana
state police raided the office of a
group that helped black and low-income
people register to vote they were
originally suspected of forging voter
registration forms no one has been
charged because it was discovered that
the suspicions were because they were
comparing the groups forms to outdated
state voter rolls I mean just bogus okay
pence cheered the entire investigation
and then this is where we really get
into the thick of it the vice-chair of
this commission on election integrity is
going to be none other than I hope
you're sitting down Kansas secretary of
state Kris Kobach who has been sued by
the ACLU for voter suppression not once
not twice not three times but four times
and has lost those lawsuits to the ACLU
not once not twice not three times but
all four times ko Bach is the person
that the White House has
sited when addressing Trump's unproven
voter fraud claims this is a closed loop
of logic right Trump says three to five
million people voted illegally really
well where'd you get that information Oh
Kris Kobach is a book believes that
we're right oh really the guy who works
for you and himself has a long track
record of suppressing voter turnout we
could not first of all we could not be
solving a problem that was less of a
problem than this one and we could not
have worse people trying to solve the
non-existent problem and are we to
believe that had Donald Trump won the
popular vote by three million instead of
losing it by three million that he'd
still be on this topic it really just
looks as if he's trying to find people
that will agree with them Republicans in
Congress won't agree with them as a
lawyers won't so if it means using
government resources to create a
commission and find the right guy he'll
do it and if it works right if Kovac is
able to influence four of federal policy
on this so that enough voter ID rules
are implemented think of the voter
suppression that this will lead to it
would result in a systemic change on a
national scale Kobach has already called
for the National Voter Registration Act
to be amended to require people to
provide proof of citizenship to register
to vote again it's not about wanting
non-citizens to vote it's that showing
proof of citizenship requires documents
that if you don't have and many people
don't you have to pay to obtain in the
past
Trump has consulted Kovac about the
Muslim ban about a Muslim registry about
the border wall about mass deportations
Kovac clearly has Trump's ear and that's
really scary and all of this especially
who Trump chooses to lead this effort
it's all a sign that voter suppression
is a goal of this commission it's or
this is Orwellian a lot of things we've
talked about are not so much Orwellian
but more reminiscent of brave new world
by Aldous Huxley this is straight-up
Orwellian the idea of a president
election integrity commission that
actually is going to try to suppress the
vote this is very scary stuff and
obviously the integrity of our elections
is very important so that's why maybe
it's not a great idea to
khalood with the Russians or a foreign
agency to get you elected also it's why
we need to update the system of electing
these officials so things like the
Electoral College don't exist anymore
there are ways there are systemic ways
you can modify how we do elections and
this goes at the local level and this
goes all the way up to the federal level
as pat is talking about but none of
these are on the horizon again when you
have a party that benefits from fewer
people voting why on earth would they
allow the system to be changed to get
more people to vote they don't want more
people to vote kind of a weird thing in
a representative democracy you would
want it to be representative of as many
people as possible but I guess not
we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
voicemail that came in i like this one
take a listen to this this is david
calling from lake harmony is wondering
why the Trump administration still is
trying to get travel ban and stated
since it's been more than 90 days since
the original attempt to put it in place
and so they should be done the research
as to quote what the hell is going on
thanks yeah this is a good point which
is this is a top priority right we're
going to shut down Muslim immigration
until we can figure out according to the
president what the hell is going on
haven't we had over a hundred days now
to figure out what the hell is going on
can trump come to us and say hey here's
what the hell is going on
he's clearly telling the Russians in the
Oval Office what the hell is going on
with Isis related Intel but what about
telling the American people what the
hell is going on with regard to the
Muslim immigration problem that he
claims exists yeah that was such a
strange moment in American history in
December of 2015 when he made that
announcement because remember Trump was
reading something off of a paper as if
it was his big policy proposal yeah and
who wrote down the words until we figure
out what the hell is going on that just
doesn't sound like it would work maybe
he ad-libbed that part I don't know but
in any case we should know by this point
what the hell is going on on the bonus
show today number one Mars astronauts
may spend a year orbiting the moon
training for the eventual trip to Mars
Tennessee is making Community College
free for all adults with some
stipulations but they're pretty
reasonable stipulations and endless soda
and potato chips at a cardiology office
what is that about I will tell you on
today's bonus show go to david
pakman.com slash membership to sign up
for membership that will give you
instant access to the bonus show you can
also make a pledge of any amount even a
dollar a month at patreon.com slash
geared attack
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
you